you gotta lose this guy who is it  doesn't matter he'll kill both of us  promise me something yeah don't follow  me  [Music]  if I just had some cash I get some  treatment maybe see my son be more think  you can help me somehow I do but I can't  do it alone  I make possible man's innate desire to  be challenged in a high lean in sport  hunting you'd want them to hunt me like  paintball  like tag or something the sport in its  purest form a hunt to kill it's a  24-hour deposits increase every hour you  survive for a grand total of twenty four  point five million dollars just you on  your own  trust no one is a paranoid when does it  start it just did  you  you